je m'appelle lorima rulin j'ai 23 ans je
suis petit je suis plus
je crois que j'ai assez bavarde genre
avoir toujours la gueule ouverte si vous
voyez un société j'essaie souvent de
faire rire de divertir peu importe l'âge
ou la fonction de la personne que j'ai
en face de moi j'essaye d'être la fille
marrante la fille sympa la fille qu'on
aime bien avoir près de ça les gens qui
m'aiment pas trop disent que je suis un
sol en moi je préfère dire que je suis
spontanée c'est mignon spontanée non je
pense que je n'ai pas besoin de vous en
dire beaucoup plus vous l'aurez vu de
vous même je suis le prototype parfait
de la fille rigolote mais
professionnellement incompétente
j'ai des lunettes pourtant mais je sais
pas clairement il ya un truc qui cloche
je le sais parce que même moi des fois
quand je me regarde je crois voir ce que
les autres voient je veux dire on sait
que les petit monde de 23 ans sont là
pour être des personnages des
caricatures on sait bien qu'en société
notre rôle essentiel à jouer c'est être
une sorte de caution séduction plus ou
moins volontaire et plus ou moins
maîtrisés personne ne l'a jamais
vraiment dit mais c'est comme ça on le
sait je ne sais pas ce que je le vois
par exemple quand je parle avec des
clients ou des partenaires sont toujours
contents de me voir ils rigolent ils me
font plein de compliments sur mon jeune
âge mon dynamisme et puis dès que ça
vient un peu sérieux on se tourne vers
menace aussi un homme un peu plus âgé
moi je continue de dire oui oui
l'histoire de valider puis voilà quoi
après tout je peux m'en prendre à
personne je veux dire je vois pas
comment je pourrais être compétente
j'ai 23 ans et j'ai passé 20 ans de ma
vie à faire du ski
je déconne pas vingt ans de ma vie je
suis originaire de la station des gets
mes parents m'ont mise au ski tout petit
comme le faut absolument tous les
parents dans les stations de ski
et puis très vite on s'est rendu compte
que j'étais pas trop mauvaise c'est pas
tant le ski que gm est d'ailleurs ce que
j'ai mais par dessus tout c'était de
gagner
cadettes quel plaisir d'être meilleur
que mon frère n'avait pas vraiment de
prix que le plaisir d'être meilleur que
les autres
globalement n'avait pas vraiment de prix
enfin si le riz dit consacrer ma vie je
me suis très vite retrouver sur le
circuit des athlètes de haut niveau
le parcours classique entraînement
entraînement entraînement compétition
médaille entraînement sport études et où
je crois que j'ai un fort caractère mais
proches disent mauvais caractère
franchement je trouve ça totalement
exagéré un fort caractère c'est tout
accepter ça va servir aux sports quand
je pourrai les commentateurs disaient
que j'étais une teigneuse un petit
roquet je le prenais comme un compliment
à l'époque mais avec le recul je sais
pas s'ils disaient vraiment ça comme ça
j'aime pas les choses injustes et je
sais pas me taire je n'accepte pas
l'inaccessible je n'accepte pas qu'on
m'interdise de croire en quelque chose
si j'en ai envie
ça devrait être une qualité mais je sais
pas apparemment je suis catalogué comme
chiante jamais trop compris ce que ça
voulait dire chiante chiante c'est un
truc qu'on dit aux filles qui veulent
pas fermer leur gueule je crois un truc
qu'on dit aux filles qui refusent de se
contentait d'une situation qu'on leur
impose et qui ne leur paraît pas
acceptable
grâce à ma grande gueule soit disant mon
insolence
j'ai été conduite a acquitté de ce qui
suit est ce qu'ils appellent à s'est
lâchement une divergence avec mon
entraîneur conduite à quitter c'est la
version édulcorée de virer
et puis ma carrière aurait pu s'arrêter
là mais comme j'avais entendu que
j'étais une teigneuse je me suis nourri
de cette force de cette rage d'être
forcés d'arrêter pour me relancer un peu
au pif en skicross par soif de revanche
pas envie de prouver à moi même et
surtout de prouver à ceux qui avaient
voulu me stopper que j'étais pas prêtes
de m'arrêter trois ans plus tard j'étais
championne de france de skicross et
vice-championne d'europe
alors voila merci à ceux qui m'ont viré
son but serait jamais arrivé quelques
jours après ma plus belle médaille ma
fédération m'appelle me convoque avec
mes parents pour m'annoncer tout
simplement mon exclusion
mon entraîneur mais steam est ingérable
insolente probablement on se refait pas
quand on est petit et blondin
apparemment quelles que soient vos
résultats
il est toujours plus simple de se taire
on devrait nous apprendre à l'école
parce que franchement moi j'ai du mal à
l'intégrer ma fédération d'ailleurs
trouvé utile de préciser à mes parents
que j'avais été mal éduqués
rassurez-vous il n'a absolument jamais
été évoqué que peut-être j'ai pu savoir
raison que ma colère n'était pas un
choix mais une nécessité que les
conditions d'entraînement n'était pas
équitable que j'étais mise à l'écart que
j'avais pas forcément tort d'avoir
ouvert ma gueule mais c'étaient les
autres qu'ils avaient tort de ne pas
l'avoir fait le manque de courage de la
majorité ne rend pas acceptable une
situation qui ne l'est pas
mais je n'ai à cause des fientes
rappelez vous et ça c'est vraiment
pratique
quand quelqu'un veut vous éloigner alors
vous vous dites que peut-être malgré
tout mes bons résultats m'avait apporté
m'avait donné confiance
ça m'avait rendu forte et pleine
d'assurance ce serait oublier un peu
vite que dans notre société on nous fait
bien comprendre que le sport ça sert à
rien le sport c'est un loisirs les
sports c'est pour s'amuser
le sport c'est pour canaliser les
exciter les moues de travail c'est autre
chose et c'est vrai une fois ma carrière
d'athlète brusquement terminer quelle
était la vie qui m'attendait j'avais
bien intégré limité vous savez bien
obtenu mais diplôme en sports études
mais je n'avais aucune culture
d'entreprise aucune expérience dans le
monde professionnel que tu allais
pourtant devoir intégrer et j'avais ce
sentiment bien ancrée quand on est
sportif de haut niveau de n'avoir jamais
vraiment vécu dans la vraie vie je
connaissais personne
je n'avais aucune expérience en rien et
j'étais toujours petite blonde et
caractériel en vrai j'étais mal parti
j'avoue alors j'ai fait ce que je savais
faire de mieux j'ai foncé sans réfléchir
dans un nouveau monde qui m'étaient
inconnues après tout ça avait marché en
skicross n'y avait pas de raison que ça
marche pas dans la vraie vie alors j'ai
trouvé mon premier stage auprès doigt ou
une agence de com à cluses la seule à
avoir répondu à mon cv très approximatif
et puis parfois la chance vous sourit
thomas qui était mon maître de stage est
lui aussi un ancien sportif de haut
niveau il m'a donné ma chance m'a formé
m'inciter à bosser toujours plus et à
faire toujours mieux
il m'a apporté toute son expérience et
je lui donnais toute mon énergie
cette collaboration est devenu un duo ça
commençait à ces agréments ressembler ce
que j'avais vécu dans le sport j'avais
de nouveau envie de foncer de nouveau
envie de gagner il nous fallait un
objectif
notre coupe du monde en quelque sorte
alors ensemble on a décidé de créer
notre entreprise d'événementiel sportif
qui s'appelle we play
je suis devenu son associé et en moins
de 10 mois on a réussi à convaincre 70
entreprises et réunir 750 participants à
notre première événements divers au
carreau ça a été dur ça a été intense
ça a été un certain mais la victoire
était belle c'était ma nouvelle médaille
d'or et j'ai compris un truc c'est que
les entrepreneurs sont en fait des
sportifs de haut niveau qui s'ignore je
retrouve dans ma nouvelle vie des
associés exactement les mêmes
problématiques que dans le sport
préparer ma saison définir mes objectifs
affronter une concurrence qui sort
parfois nulle part apprendre à me faire
confiance
mon tour et des bonnes personnes
acceptez mes erreurs m'engueuler avec
mon coach comblé mes faiblesses je
retrouve les mêmes sacrifices
l'impossibilité d'avoir une vie privée
l'obsession de la réussite que j'avais
tant quand je courais alors certains ont
plus d'expérience plus de finance plus
d'exposition médiatique
il faut l'accepter ne pas de victimiser
mais comme dans le sport en entreprise
rien est impossible rien n'est écrit
d'avancé
il est succès ni les échecs on appris
par exemple la difficile décision avec
we play d'annuler un événement faute de
parvenir à le financer
chaque fois
ces sentiments de repartir de zéro ne
pas être au niveau
ce sentiment que je connaissait si bien
quand j'étais en skicross
chaque fois la nécessité de devoir se
relever de lutter contre l'envié
d'abandonner ainsi va mal mais je
continue de foncer
j'ai enfin confiance en ma capacité de
fonçage en fait je crois que j'avais
tout simplement trop longtemps confondu
compétences et expériences
je commence à me sentir un peu moins
seul dans cet étrange monde des
dirigeants d'entreprise
parce que c'est un monde où mon
insolence est enfin devenue une qualité
c'est un monde où mon obsession de
gagner est une des clés pour avancer
c'est un monde où je m'ennuie jamais
c'est un monde où je n'ai plus à prouver
ma légitimité à qui que ce soit c'est un
monde où je peux tout avoir à condition
de faire des sacrifices pour y arriver
c'est un monde où personne ne peut plus
rien interdire alors oui apparemment je
suis blonde est petit et chiante et je
serais probablement toujours plus
inexpérimentés quelqu'un peut-être aussi
parce que je serais probablement
toujours là on ne m'attend pas parce que
j'aime relever des défis
quel qu'il soit parce que le sport m'a
donné cette force de toujours me relever
de ne pas abandonner
est ce que je serais probablement
toujours contente de parler fort de
râler de faire rire et d'être insolente
parce que c'est chouette
parce que c'est moi on dit toujours aux
parents de recadrer les gens comme moi
que si on rentre pas dans le cadre on
n'ira pas bien loin qu'il vaut mieux se
taire quand on est jeune et qu'on n'a
pas d'expérience alors désolé désolé
mais je suis là désolé mais je suis
comme ça j'essaie juste de faire ma
place de faire ce que j'aime et d'être
heureuse alors peut-être qu'un jour avec
un peu de chance quand vous croiserez
une petite blonde insolente vous
réussirez à lui imaginé un passé une
histoire des réussites et des échecs des
projets
les objectifs et des rêves
vous ne la verrez plus seulement comme
un simple instrument de divertissement
[Applaudissements]